wir sagen unseren punktestand 32
hannover ist luca meine damen und herren
hier seht ihr habt ihr wieder ins rad
vorbereitet mit vielen verschiedenen
buchstaben und außerdem ist mir ja wir
haben uns überlegt dass wir heute mal
wieder eine glücksrad stadt land fluss
challenge machen und zwar haben wir im
letzten video wo wir das auch schon
gemacht haben beruf habe ich in diesem
video konntet ihr uns oben in die
kommentare schreiben welche kategorien
wie bei einem zweiten teil dass beim
heutigen video nehmen sollen und dieser
kommentarschreiber haben gewonnen er hat
uns sechs kategorien vorgeschlagen da
wird das ganze allerdings nur mit vier
kategorien spielen haben wir uns für die
kategorien entschieden was er andere
liebt was der andere hastete zur sache
und eine essen oder ein getränk zu
drehen das ist jetzt nicht so oft
umgedreht das glücksrad aber was gibst
du denn mit ich keine ahnung was du mit
dem auch diesmal nur buchstaben genommen
wie beim letzten mal noch nicht hatten
also wenn er auch andere kategorien aber
alles okay gut aber ich habe den ersten
stopp gesagt das heißt wenn ich etwas
haben sollte das über auch aber dann
bekomme ich in dem fall den punkt also
eine sache die du magst mit habe ich
unternehmungen du machst wenn man etwas
unternimmt
okay das heißt in dem fall kriegen jetzt
weiter 1 punkte bei einer sache die du
hast habe ich umleitungen dass ich also
wir sind unglaublich echt egal weil ich
meinen beifahrer
ja also vom binger wald ich würde sagen
kriegen beide keinen punkt blödes wort
ist todesursache habe ich unfall
[Musik]
wir sagen bei essen beziehungsweise
getränk habe mich ehrlich ja okay da
krieg ich habe die packen jetzt jeder
den vettel bei seinem eine damen und
herren umgedreht dass wir nicht auf die
punkte schauen und ich blende euch auch
extra wieder keine punkte stand hier ein
so dass am ende die punkte gezählt
werden dann geschaut wird wer gewonnen
hat wir können uns übrigens auch jetzt
wieder kategorien fürs nächste mal und
in die kommentare schreiben
also wenn ihr denkt hey das können wir
aber der kategorie machen dann schrecken
kommt dann wird er in seiner lieben
freunde um der nächste zum start mit dem
in die kategorie machen müssen sb muss
man das waren ja kleinlich und wird das
hätte ich wahrscheinlich
was magst du mit b was was was war da
was liebe dich habe ich bella wäre
wüsste ich werde auch bilder aufstellen
könnte hat irgend etwas das du hast habe
ich blitze aufgeschrieben
ok ich sagte du jetzt auch beleidigungen
beleidigungen aufgeschrieben aber dafür
viele augen drogen geld koste sachen
abfall ins gesicht aufgeschrieben
ich wollte es aufschreibt und bürger
verschluckt aber ich hab es nicht mehr
geschafft liegen derzeit habe ich zum
glück ich habe burger ok wenig habe ich
noch zwei punkte bekommen jahrhundert
hier wieder und der buchstabe k s steht
immer noch zu haben
[Musik]
keine ahnung
da porto leben zu ende schreiben will
was wir uns die liebsten habe ich
kräuter linge ich habe mir
aufgeschrieben ja ich mache dinge dass
der italienische geburt mit ihm kann man
meiner meinung nach alles würzen aber du
magst du weißt was du hast habe ich
kratzige pullover da zählt nicht also
ich hab mir gedacht das wort an sich
muss mit car anfangen
gar nichts soll sollte jeder die auf
zehn gehabt wurde es der sache habe ich
kann er tritt ich habe klavier fällt auf
den kopf
camille betroffenen dringend asse habe
ich gar nicht sichert willkommen
hochgenommen der erste buchstabe wir
hier von mir aus und das trifft die
ganze zeit um sie doch das soll mir
nicht gut weg sein was du liebst mit
2000 jahre später
[Musik]
ja aber ich habe schon gesagt was liebst
habe ich computer aufgeschrieben
okay das perfekt was du hast habe ich
klar jeder hat diesen klauen von diesem
film bei todesursache aber ich emi
explosion
das ist das gleiche
[Musik]
hast du direkt war es letztes mal hatten
wir nur sechs runden
dies machen wir das ganz europa stoppt
auf acht runden fleck hat die green aber
acht runden dieses gewinnt immer noch 1
was wäre dir ja ja
[Musik]
was du liebst habe ich dass mehr mädchen
erfasst habe ich jetzt gerade auf dem
lande entzündung ja das ist richtig gut
oder der todesursache habe ich ein
meerestier hat einen aufgeblähten haie
oder so höre verschluckt und bei essen
habe ich mal aber auch kuchen
seid ihr euch fragt warum will ich hier
schon zweimal boere aufgeschrieben hatte
im rudel bei früher nicht verliebte
möhren und hat auf ihrem blog ich gucke
da kann man die beschreibung da ist ein
link zur julis mögen bei zutaten
verzichtet die ares reden und der
nächste bus statt mit dem hammer spvg
[Musik]
bei dem was du liebst habe ich auch
wichtige spiele ich habe verheimlichen
nein ich dachte dass wir aufpassen
online ich dachte du hasst es wenn man
verlieren was wir heute wissen dass dies
ein bei dem das zuerst habe ich verkehr
ich habe vogel taktisch gut wurde so
weit habe ich verkehrsunfall
ich habe von rapid zu fallen deswegen
habe ich gott da habe ich nicht wollte
ja stimmen zur letzten runde war dem
star ein paar sekunden später was das
ist nicht wahr ich schaff's nicht mal
das fertig zuschneiden schreiben genau
was du liebst euch abgeschrieben weil
den liebsten ja auch eine
freundschaftliche art und weise frieden
aufgeschrieben also meine wird aber auf
jeden fall mehr hintergrund sehr dass du
hast habe ich schwitze aufgestiegen bei
dem maxi keine pilze das stimmt ich habe
fans dabei nacht offen und bei essen und
trinken habe ich kannte ja da habe ich
nichts verraten regt mich das aufsetzen
die deutschen spiele werden mit dem
buchstaben gegeben direkt man gehe
weiterhin geschrieben
[Musik]
du bist ein arschloch elbe was hast du
liebst du mich auch nicht
unglaublich habe gurgeln oft schreiben
ja immer wenn er die mit jedem
burkhalter
was hast du hast da habe ich bleiben mir
geraten grünkohl grünkohl an
ich habe gar nichts also für beide
kämpfe welt wurdest du sagen habe ich
getreideunverträglichkeit das war so ein
langes worten hätte spiels doch nicht an
der getreideunverträglichkeit in einer
ziemlich wenn das überreagiert nein du
bist echt hautausschlag du hast
aufgeschrieben fallobst bestimmt seit
ich finde und ab laufen gekommen
wenn du damit großen ja ok ich hab' glas
verschluckt und reden du warst ja es
klingt auf grünkohl
ich habe glas cola du hattest gerade
ratio pullover ja aber das ist etwas
anderes als glas cola weil das cola ist
mir das getriebe des pullover das was
ich danach kriegenburgs oder durch war
auch wenn das später der funktion wieder
verliere das wissen woran es lag also
900 war der grund warum ich euch jetzt
wieder nicht den punktestand eingewendet
habe sondern dass wir jetzt diesen
überraschungsmoment haben und ich zähle
jetzt die punkte zusammen und dann
schauen wir
wer der gewinner ist houellebecq in
slate glücklich am ball gerade
durchgezählt
wir sagen unseren punktestand 321 200
watt 27 das kann sein ja es sind 27
und wer an der stelle durch das heutige
video allerdings beendet meine damen und
herren ich hoffe euch hat diese stadt
land fluss glücksrad challenge gefallen
danke nochmal an den kommentarschreiber
hier für einen wundervollen kategorie
kommentar falls ihr das ganze format
tool findet und euch denkt hey mach das
doch mal mit den kategorien hin schreibt
das geld in die kommentare 1 kommentar
mit vier kategorien
die wir beim nächsten mal verwenden
sollen und dann gib dem video daumen
hoch
du solltest wegrollen
[Musik]